otto é que o aquecimento de voz que tudo
isto é fácil é bom diz pessoal aqui quem
fala é o dar que sejam muito bem vindos
e mais um vídeo e o estrago já que é que
nem ter sua luta em vídeo é que nem
vocês deram muito ao que lá e cá e
também comentaram bastante bons
anfitriões melhor em campo bom a bola
procurar personagem é nossa primeira
sugestão foi a tua namorada dark o seu
personagem existe na vida real se você
está em um canal de jogos não comece já
está em 100 o seu personagem já vem ao
brasil o primeiro salão brasília na opel
está já a receber o título de santa só
serão suspensos gum minha namorada eu
ser caso eu não imagino um buraco tranca
a responder que não seu personagem é
brasileiro e katherine a mãe portuguesa
meio brasileira no fim não sabe como é
costume isso então ok eu vou responder
que não porque senão vai associar um
gamer do brasil por isso vou dizer que
não o seu estágio é bom e parkour não eu
nunca havia saltado varandas nem prédios
no seu estágio faz parte minecraft do
fio também na o seu personagem é o
youtube para que está o pulo aqui nem
ter cria o seu personagem tem um canal
do terror e tecnicamente ela faz mais
curto com outras coisas por isso vamos
dizer que sim o seu personagem tem
cabelos pretos na o seu personagem é uma
mulher
sim aqui na itália é uma mulher o seu
estágio mora no estádio jamor uma já
namora o seu personagem homossexual eu
já me perguntaram se eu era cercado e
agora tenho uma pergunta ser homossexual
meu o que falta aqui não não é
homossexual o seu personagem usa é
perguntas são extra no seu estágio em
portugal assim ô ô ô será quase a flip
ou é sério é impossível impossível
enganar o a caneta mas digam lá que não
é linda é bom vamos lá próximo de deixar
o pai de família a a robô para procurar
o pai sumiu e não se eu não devo dar né
eu achei o cenário geral somente o seu
estágio é o youtube
eu acho que não acho que eu vou fazer
com os filhos lado os queimar a rosca em
estágios roupas femininas
ok eu vou dizer que não sai da sua
personagem conhece você pessoalmente
nunca
o que na vida eu não tenciono conhecer o
pai de família porque o pai é um homem
muito respeito
não não conheço o tipo de imagem do
gênero feminino não chantagem é famoso
pelo futebol bem na o seu personagem
vive em portugal bem não é do brasil que
seu personagem é real a ice ou bem real
cara frio é real não era euro o dólar e
piada um simples imagem viva da música
só por aquela música do ppe postagem é
brasileiro para que está uma pergunta
que já se arrasta pelo menos se está a
gente trabalha na televisão não acho que
não o seu estágio ficou famoso graças à
internet hora que está mais uma que você
tem personagem gay eu acho que sim
roger é um ator pornô que sim vai por si
já que o geílson alguns minutos se o
personagem toma suco de laranja assim
sim o pai dormindo e toma-se um laranja
se o nosso com um sonho seu personagem
tem barriga
não acho que vai ficar agora vai ficar o
meu deus caiu na internet a lenta o que
vinha cheio não pode ser não foi né
escreveu sharia annan
eu quero que o a cnar torque na tora
devine eu mesmo será que eu consigo
imaginar assim sexagem youtuber não o
seu personagem do gênero feminino não
tem bigode né vai encaminhar também tem
bigode e pronto a reportagem é famoso
sem o personagem famoso pelo futebol o
seu estágio mora no seu país não mora
nintendo né
não sei que tem jeito vou responder que
não sai há nela mora lá no geral fez uma
paisagem um atraso e não fala depois de
tê-la no geral isso muito burros e
postagens fácil definições sim em fase
de definições o seu personagem gosta de
fazer perguntas se seu personagem tem
entre 20 e 25 anos
eu tenho até país 30 40 vou dizer que
não sai o seu personagem faz parte de 1
1 biliões mico que é isso não sai então
filme uma novela não sair eu vou dizer
que não porque nem mesmo é que nem deve
participar nisso né ai ai vai ficar
assim que o tio do ac na o tio do atleta
eu disse que o tio do akneton aqui eu
vou considerar aquilo que viu porque o
brasil a imagem de louie igual sem
nenhum por isso é para não dá pra
enganar este ano a próxima gestão e
rumar tem firmino e orides já me
chamaram e como é que nem sempre podem
encontrar um fantasma mexicano que nunca
existiu vamos lá estou procurando chaves
o personagem que ficou famosos em vídeos
é não foi charlie charlie que fez foram
as pessoas que faziam os troxa de chave
o que vou dizer que sim porque eu
principado em vídeos né
sim o personagem esteve no brasil já
deixava e viram o mundo eu tento do
lápis e postagens tempo no brasil a cair
eu vou dizer que não sai o seu estágio
em vivem em portugal dizem que o charlie
charlie mexicano por isso eu vivo há no
méxico não se estágio em vendeu a alma
opa vendeu a alma e lombe e os demônios
possuírem moniz de fantasma mal eu
sempre me a alma disse sim sim o seu
personagem faz vídeos sobre games não se
está a gerir o gênero feminino também
não o seu estágio faz vídeos de humor
não já vi sharlei coisa do paranormal do
seu personagem vive da música também não
seu estágio é uma turba eu faço um
cipreste pergunta por que atacou usar o
olho se o personagem é o youtube não dão
mole o seu personagem já por si uma tv
acho que não acho que só possuem viris
mesmo é não o seu personagem é um animal
também não o seu personagem começa com a
letra do seu nome para o seu personagem
começa com a letra do sono assim eu acho
que tudo o personagem começa com a letra
do seu nome
não to terceira pergunta não aqui né
tasman confundir o cérebro já vou dizer
que sim o protótipo ele chama charbil
comece um dentro do seu novo golpe
momento o seu estágio inicial antes você
puxa não já não sei né eu vou dizer que
não saiba o seu personagem possui poder
de água eu tenho pedido do map eu acho
que isso não vai conseguir definir o seu
personagem fomos graças de esportes
aquáticos também não
jatene seu elenco principal nos lápis
estamos na pergunta 18 eu não consegui
nada ainda o seu personagem tem me dado
que você não sair mas não deve ser um
nome vende aqui você dona do seu
personagem não seu personagem brasileiro
não deve checar o seu personagem de um
jogo
supostamente que o rn é um jogo é sim
seu personagem é mau é mau sem nossa
mexicano é que o personagem tem cabelo
longo
olhe eu acho que todo mônica tem aquela
câmera gigante de quais uma que eu leve
com luan eu vou dizer que não saia o seu
personagem usa uma máscara também não
sai meu pai e eu foquei em demônio a
ilsinho
ae acho que é cair ou não eu não to
bring cara eu to fotografia não eu não
to black é possível eu ando filfogo chap
chap emendou urbana eu vou ficar onde
estava para um carro xsara agora então é
isso pessoal vamos ficar por aqui com
espírito e espero que vocês tenham
gostado e como vocês podem ver é
completamente impossível enganar
maquinetas fizeram as vidas daqueles já
sabem deixe nos comentários sugestões
promacchina estranhar por favor comentem
coisas difíceis dois só sabem quanto
como franco favorito fiquem bem até a
próximo verão